des gens c'était plus près de 25000
étudiants et travailleurs qui étaient
dans le programme d'expérience
québécoise donc le niveau de
l'immigration à 60 000 va être bonifiée
et ça sur une période continuelle par
ceux et celles qui seront via le
programme d'expérience québécoise donc
le 60 000 de 2027 serait davantage 60
quelques milles et quelques milliers de
plus qui viendraient du programme de
l'expérience tout à fait si on prend le
chiffre de 21 de 2021 c'est près de
24000 travailleurs et étudiants qui
étaient sous le programme d'expérience
québécois et avant ils étaient inclus
dans le total de l'immigration comme par
exemple à 50000 maintenant ils vont être
additionnés à ce 50 000 ou à 160000
dépendamment des discussions qui auront
lieu à l'Assemblée nationale
ce serait 60 000 + 20 000 exactement
parce que 80% pour être ça ces gens sont
déjà ils sont au Québec sont déjà
intégrés sont déjà en appartement sont
aux études veulent travailler alors ces
gens au la capacité de faire leur
demande rapidement et de procéder de
façon très rapide en lien avec les
annonces qui ont été faites aujourd'hui
à Québec sur 50 et 60 000 affaires mais
ce que vous me dites c'est qu'avec le
programme de l'expérience québécoise ça
ressemblerait davantage à 70-80 mille
par année dépendamment combien qu'il y
aura de gens qui sont sur ce programme
là mais ça va venir s'additionner au 50
ou 60 000 qui sera le seuil établi par
le gouvernement on sent que le
gouvernement veut des immigrants
francophones clairement francophones
est-ce que de ce côté là il y a pas des
exigences supplémentaires qui pourraient
faire en sorte qu'il est moins simple
pour certains travailleurs de s'intégrer
au marché du travail du Québec il y a
des exigences plus importantes pour la
francisation d'ailleurs nous étions
d'accord avec la volonté du Premier
ministre de tendre vers une immigration
100% francophone nous avions quand même
apporté certaines nuances on donne on ne
devait pas se priver d'un talent
exceptionnel parce qu'il ne parlait pas
le français et c'est ce qui s'est
retrouvé aujourd'hui dans le
présentation mais en même temps avec
l'exigence du français dépendamment des
catégories qui sont élaborées qui sont
précisés dans les différentes annonces
d'aujourd'hui il y aura des niveaux qui
seront différents de le niveau 7 par
exemple au niveau de du français oral
versus un niveau 5 versus le français
écrit donc il y aura des distinctions
c'est très important en sachant qu'au
Québec actuellement il y a une personne
sur deux malheureusement qui n'est pas
plus élevé que le niveau 3 dans la
société en général la société en général
entre 15 et 60 et 4 ans donc ça vient
pas freiner l'accès au marché du travail
pour les immigrants ça vient offrir des
opportunités différentes dans un
contexte de notre langue à titre
d'exemple actuellement nous sommes près
de 320 millions de francophones dans le
monde dit une quarantaine d'années c'est
plus d'un milliard de francophones qui
seront dans le monde alors il y a une
opportunité pour le Québec et je pense
que dans ce qui était annoncé
aujourd'hui ça va exactement dans la
bonne direction est-ce que les
changements sont importants pour le
retour des programmes investisseurs
programme entrepreneurs également tout à
fait vous le savez programme
investisseur immigrants investisseur
était mis de côté depuis plusieurs
années nous avons milité longuement pour
qu'il puisse être réinscrit aujourd'hui
les annonces du gouvernement viennent
réinscrire sur ce programme investisseur
mais on va faire favoriser davantage les
investisseurs francophones c'est correct
mais au moins on relance ce programme
qui est extrêmement important et qui
peut générer des retombées économiques
importantes pour le Québec tout en étant
bien évidemment accueilli avec des gens
qui vont venir investir dans la société
il y aura plus d'immigrants en région
avec le programme d'aujourd'hui cela
définitivement les besoins sont partout
à travers les régions du Québec alors
avec les annonces qui sont faites
aujourd'hui il y aura certainement des
opportunités incroyables de régionaliser
l'immigrations il faut savoir que la
régionalisation elle existe déjà est-ce
qu'on en veut davantage bien évidemment
dans la région de Gaspésie dans la
région du syndelac St-Jean dans la
région de la Côte Nord il y a déjà des
travailleurs immigrants qui sont dans
les entreprises actuellement est-ce
qu'on peut faire plus est-ce qu'on peut
faire mieux bien évidemment la réponse
est oui le Premier ministre le goût
avait été critique à votre endroit parce
que vous avez souvent critiqué le
gouvernement sur la question de
l'immigration on entend l'âge de guerre
je crois qu'il y avait une hache de
guerre de déterrer mais c'est
complètement autre chose aujourd'hui on
répond à vos demandes on répond aux
demandes des employeurs et je pense que
c'est ça qui est important de le
rappeler en 2021 monsieur Fillon nous
avons dévoilé des recommandations on
avait fait 18 recommandations qui
faisait à conseiller tant le
gouvernement du Québec que le
gouvernement fédéral pour régulariser
les problématiques reliées à
l'immigration il n'y en avait 10 qui
étaient directement adressé au
Gouvernement du Québec de ces 10 9 se
retrouvent aujourd'hui dans les
programmes qui ont été annoncés alors
effectivement on est très heureux de ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui on va
collaborer c'est un bon score pour les
emplois les employeurs québécois c'est
un bon score pour l'économie québécoise
parce qu'on le sait la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre malheureusement a des
conséquences économiques
atives et dans les annonces qui ont été
faites le temps va certainement donner
raison au gouvernement et au
préoccupations plus avion merci Monsieur
Blackburn merci à vous pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI